[Music]
okay we just got done seeing a Lita
battle angel again for the second time
this time we saw it in HD or whatever
just the regular yeah we just thought
right because first time we saw that 3d
now I should say that like soft 3d in
Dolby yeah it was good like I know like
maybe people would be like oh you're
cheap like 3d movies just like that's
what you guys there was nothing nothing
more to watch this weekend we had wanted
to see Lita again anyway so we figured
we would use that as one of the slots
and the other yes we decided that if
we're forced to watch like another dog
move your solution we'd rather go back
and watch like the best movie of that
month and see it again and see if it
holds up to repeat viewings yeah in the
case of battle angel I actually thought
it was better on the second think it was
because I mean the first time I wasn't
familiar with like how the story's gonna
go so you really had to like pay
attention there was like a lot it's kind
of a complicated yeah packed a lot in
two hours yeah yeah so you have to you
know and it's all this world building
and stuff like that so since I already
knew how the story gonna go and are
anything other world works you know now
I could like concentrate more on you
know character motivations I could
concentrate more on how it looked like
the score you know the Senate talk to it
like that so I actually think I
appreciated it much more sometime and I
have to say I liked it better not in
yeah I could I think it was a little bit
easier to keep track of everything
vision yeah and it looks kind of cooler
it almost had like a little bit of more
of a Blade Runner II kind of yeah it has
a lot better music than I remembered
yeah score on the Beckett's epic has an
epic score toward the end the way it was
you know she was getting ready to go to
the motor ball championship and just the
score that was playing in the back was
they were building it up it was like
some just like some [ __ ] out of Empire
Strikes Back
yeah and like I said that's it really
does seem like Oh
I'm glad it held them the second time I
thought it would because I liked it the
first time yeah but you know it's like I
said it's much cooler like seeing the
second time because I caught a lot more
stuff that I did that's before like did
you catch the I didn't see this the
first time but the part where Hugo goes
in the bar wouldn't like the big
Grishka or whatever his name is when he
was in and Hugo glances down at his leg
and he's like oh that's that part I
jacked like second time he was like
looking down like okay yeah there's a
lot of little details like little
details that you know that's the first
time but like I said since I was
familiar with the story like I could
kind of like look for yeah things like
that and if so it was like much enhanced
like saying did you notice that we she
got the Martian Berserker am a berserker
body when it was just hanging in there
it was androgynous it looked at Mayo
when she got in it became yeah well he
did like the doctor to say that that
girl that when when it was all like
attached and everything like that it
started like making micro adjustments to
her subconscious okay what would it look
like so I guess the bodies are either
male or female - yeah they're just like
generic blanks and then they attach it
to a core yeah you know whatever that
person's core they're yeah I didn't
catch it the first one of them to look
like then that's what it will adjust it
don't look like so yeah so yeah we'll be
held up excellent movie still I'm gonna
say you know one of the best movies of
the month at least oh yeah all right Wow
look at it
[Music]
okay we just got done seeing one called
hotel Mumbai and it's about a terrorist
attack that happened what was it 2000
2008 2008 in India vataj yeah ma oh it
was like 12 other sites yes 10
terrorists attacked and they hit in
various 12 12 sites various locations
and they kind of quote coalesced someone
got killed or apprehended and other
sites but coalesced around Batoche which
is a big famous hotel in India it had
all kind of all kinds of celebrities and
rich russians and and everything and it
was just a good movie the staff and
guests were trying to survive this like
a terror attack and the way it's shown
is it's very realistic and having some
training and some background and this
kind of stuff that's what it's like this
this this movies a really good tool like
a training total what a terrorist acts
like right yeah and not only does that
but it really gets you to like they you
know there's a click a core of
characters like one guy that's on the
staff like the head chef there's like
yeah a couple that's like an Indian
woman and an American man you know and
there's various like this Russian
businessman stuff like that that kind of
so there's like a handful of characters
that they kind of kind of coalesce
around in the store but they also give
up a lot of attention to the terrorists
yeah and what their motivations were and
how they died and what these guys were
like and there's you know bravery all
around with the staff and the civilians
even the nannies just a good flick man I
mean I kept almost like getting pulled
into it like I was trying to fight but I
didn't have anything I wasn't in the
mood I wasn't in the movie I couldn't do
it
the way this movie was shot it was like
you you know it you know it's about a
true terrorist attack it's like so many
people got killed at least sounds like a
couple hundred I think ended up in like
you know with hundreds of their wounded
but it just like the whole [ __ ] thing
is like the way they shot it I just felt
like sick super super just like that
like I just like you're there you know
yes and it's like it was just horrifying
like harrowing experience not a fun
movie but it was amazing it was an
amount like a disaster film a horror
movie in an action movie
all in one it's nonstop action and like
a second boy really likes it like um but
the package good
yeah like the group of characters that
it kind of focused on you man you were
like rooting for ya come on no no it's
like just the whole time and it's like
it's interesting because when I first
went to you know buy the ticket for this
movie they were only doing one show but
then I noticed that today they'd added
another one and I guess it's a good
thing they did because our video was
almost sold out yeah yeah so they added
another show movie teaches and movie
teaches a lot of lessons and backs up
some of the stuff that I said in the
commercial world the closest thing to a
soldier is a cook the cooks and all
these guys they stayed by God all of the
kitchen staff stayed to help the guests
get out and actually half of the people
that died were staff yeah and it stayed
behind because they some of them said
you know they said oh they could get out
they could leave but most of them did
not
yes stayed to like help people yeah the
Cook said no we're not going to work
yeah I think only till you run around
with knives and damn meat tenderizers
and stuff trying to yeah yeah it was
like it was awesome and like I said you
know I don't I don't like I remember
when it happened that I don't remember
yeah you know the exact same joke you
know it might have been some stuff might
have been changed or engendered for
traumatic purposes or whatever but you
know it's really really good movie like
I said it's it's not a fun time I'm
gonna tell you that right now but yeah
it was you know I was just on the edge
of my seat
another thing the story shows is it
shows India was is a pretty much as a
disarmed population that it has a really
poorly trained police force really
poorly trained is really poorly equipped
when this [ __ ] went down their version
of special forces with what eight hours
away yeah so there wasn't many Delhi no
timely response if you have any military
experience you don't you first thing you
know is that an early response even if
it's bad as always better than a late
response even if it's perfect so yeah
what you end up with this for ragbag
average ragbag terrorists with shitty
ak's running amuck killing hundreds of
people because there was no response
some like some of the cops they some of
the customs we gotta use it in apps
yeah but and they were told not to go in
by their by their channel some of the
cops that it was a bad idea and I don't
think some of them went in but they
should have done is they had hundreds of
cops with old Lee Enfield bolt action
rifles and six shot 38 special revolvers
they just should have swarmed in there
by the hundreds and got it over with
yeah you and then a lot of less people
would've died they just should have
swarmed Chinese wave attack style just
go in there that have been the way to do
it but their [ __ ] you know they
didn't have any experience in it there's
a fantastic movie III got a feel
beginner only so one trailer for this
and I was like hey that looks pretty
good
what's that play make me mad watching
this movie but I love it that [ __ ] could
have been lessened a lot he had a
response been have been a lot wait
yeah alright but I can't talk about it
we gotta move yeah
okay we just got done seeing Dumbo Dumbo
the flying elephant it's about an
elephant that flies I saw the original I
was a kid
although I don't think this had much to
do with the original I mean never a
couple scenes I recognized from a kid
like you know when they locked the mama
up and that you know and um was you know
trying to reach the ball and you know
why she's locked up in the very
beginning you know I remember that part
but a lot of the other stuff I don't
really remember because I saw the
cartoon like I
I think this kept to the pretty basic
out of it as far as I can recall yeah
they may have updated story I'm not
really sure but Tim Burton directed this
yeah it is not as Burton Diaz a lot of
other Burton Burton movies I mean it
didn't hurt well yeah you could tell it
was tempered yeah particularly when they
go to like the bigger surfaces yeah
transparently evil Michael Keaton what
is it like during 1919 yeah 1919 so you
know with this big like circus that he
has its evil Disneyland which is
Disneyland basically it's evil yeah but
honestly I think they did a pretty good
job cause I guess Disney has been doing
a lot of you know live-action reboots of
a lot of their cartoons from back in the
day even though most of it is a junkie
yeah they did being the Beast and
and also that's coming out in a couple
months and actually a lot of this was
also pretty good I like that I think I
like the kids in it performances were
good yeah I like - what's your name
that's in all the alright I'm gonna give
you the real deal though she's giving
you the candy ass deal I'm gonna give
you the real deal
the first few acts like the opening act
it was it was kind of slow because the
setting was basically boring it's out in
the country and they're trying to
establish the characters the main
characters which is a cowboy and his
daughter and his son okay and they're
trying to establish these characters but
they're basically generic they're
generic stock characters so they kind of
waste time establishing them you don't
really need to establish them they could
have just moved really the star was
Dumbo so you could have gotten you can
you could really minimize those
characters and edit it to go a little
faster because you couldn't all these
characters are generic the French
ballerina the big top guys and the
ringleaders they're all generic there's
nothing really unique about any of them
really the only thing unique about the
story is is dub oh yeah and I remember
the original story being told more would
as Dumbo as the center of attention
through the whole thing I don't really
remember and that makes more sense to me
yeah I can't remember and so maybe
somebody never mind because like I said
I
am i thinking of a band I think you're
thinking of Bambi which you know there
are darker elements in this story as
given which kind of stands up to the old
school as nice you know what I mean
where it scares the [ __ ] out of the kids
I mean you got a damn torment this
[ __ ] elephant to get it to fly and
they're doing bad [ __ ] to it and and
it's yeah and then like hit the end they
have to I mean it's taking places in a
circus man what kind of [ __ ] bummer as
[ __ ] is that you know I mean it's
[ __ ] bombers what they're doing to
those animals
you know I'm an animal lover even though
I hunt I'm an animal lover I just don't
like the [ __ ] surgeon well I don't
like [ __ ] captive animals oh yeah
yeah I was gonna say like the scene at
the beginning when they're trying to get
them to fly and they are they're making
fun of his ears or whatever I said you
know what [ __ ] these people
so there's there's like a lot of
negativity in it that's old school
and they're telling you the stories
about calming inhumane period and an
inhumane subject but then they have to
[ __ ] but at the end of the movie they
have to reverse that they did some
scenes they're like oh no we're with our
new circus doesn't have any cap
developments at it because they're
they're basically apologizing to the
they're basically apologizing to the
audience that they told you a story
about a circus if you ask me that's what
they're doing
I wouldn't have [ __ ] told this story
I wouldn't have touched Dumbo I'd have
done a new man okay the setting is bad
yeah it was a long time it was a long
time ago and they did [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
just they should have told a different
story I wouldn't touch Dumbo
yeah
it's like trying to reduce song of the
south would you do that I wouldn't do
that I wouldn't read a burden of read on
Dumbo I would have left it alone because
it's a [ __ ] bad story but anyway she
gives a thumbs up I guess and I would
give it a thumbs up based on quality but
I think that movie was in poor taste
someone get a thumbs down movie but like
I said if there are problems with
filming that story the problem with
Dumbo is that it's Dumbo it's circus
story yeah [ __ ] that
[Music]